Hello Andre Bandrod Developer Relations Team's Developer Program
ng
Today is the back of the sweet chocolate of Android 4.4
We're here to introduce you to new features.
Kiki's overseas version number is only a single decimal point.
In fact, a lot of features have been added between these little changes.
Old jellybean version of the sentence to express a word like butter
If it was Android, then this keycap version is Android for everyone.
I will.
I've put a lot of effort into optimizing the memory,
Designed to run smoothly even on low-end devices
Also for application developers
You can use api and memory to check whether the device is low memory.
Added 2 to check if you are using it effectively
Newly added Activities Manager's 2 weeks
If you use
Based on the method results, you can change the behavior of a particular feature
You can disable it altogether
A feature that requires a lot of memory is a device that uses less memory.
It can be a feature that users simply do not have
Of course, removing the feature is the last choice
Previously
First of all, if you look at the managing um memory entry in the Android developer documentation
You can find useful tips on optimizing your application's memory usage.
There is
However, before your app's memory usage improves,
You need to check how much you're using
The newly added Proxy text allows the application to
You can see at a glance whether you are using
The proxy th tool can be run as db cetace ss prox ts command
There is
Command line tree There may be burdened people There is no need to worry
Talk to Android Keti or go to the developer option of the emulator
The memory profile of the application can be identified by a menu of statistics
Added
If you press it, system memory summary information and running for more than a certain time
You can see a list of processes
The blue half is relative to the upper right corner of the memory usage
Indicates the percentage of processes running in the background
When you touch an app in the list, the average used during this app
And the maximum listing is well summarized in this information
Not all changes to the ticket go to memory
A new way to create beautiful Android apps is also easy
Added
first
The Android design guidelines have been updated
Developers can create a cool, core app and give users a magical experience
It contains information on how you can provide
For more information, see the recently updated Anjouide design action video
Please take a look
Looking at api
A full scan to fill the entire screen 2 Clean up the scene with the chewing mode
Movable Team Diction Primer The subtitle feature that many people are waiting for
New tools have been added to easily record on screen
With the new fullscreen Mercury model,
Literally from the end of the screen to the system state and the navigation bar
You can implement a full-screen ui with the system and the juxtaposition removed
To express visually rich content
For example, it might be a perfect fit for a photo hate or a pre-map game.
Will
This new mode is available via a simple flag
I am a c9 stethki flag.
It is also easy to use.
This is the code that hides or reappears the child or after chewing tk
You can also use the flag
In this case, if a certain time has elapsed or the user touches the screen,
ui disappears and is converted to full screen mode
If you want to know more about all of the new full screen is easy
Romanian glass dog chewed Owl looks at mode Daewoo Bytes video
I recommend you take a look
To make it easy for developers to apply cool animations, Android 4.4
In
Cutaway animation is a new kind of frenzy shampoo that you can perform
Added
Use animation to inform the user of ui's state change.
There are a lot of cases
This is especially true if the features supported by each state are different.
You can use the new trendy chapter framework to set the scene
There is
The scene is a transition between this particular b5 hierarchy and the night scene,
It consists of information
In the transition state, the animation information used when entering or exiting the scene
Included
You can select one of several predefined transition types
Or you can choose auto transition type to play with Android
You can also apply the appropriate animation
Like the magic, the bureau has reduced the size or the size of the deformed or deformed position
I will do it.
Of course, you can move the most appropriate aging,
You can also apply animation styles
For more information on the new transition framework,
Please refer to the video of DebutByte
System preference options have also been added to improve Android accessibility
It's about captioning.
This can be especially useful for Korean developers
Developers can use the newly added Capture Manager to
You can tell if you want to place subtitles and position,
Only to add to the video video view in the web vtt format subtitle file streamer
Screen caption is automatically set based on the user's preference value.
Is displayed
For more details, please see the treatment of Allen Librett
Please refer to the byte video
You are holding the video camera steady to capture the app demo video.
There are a lot of people who have had a hard time.
You seem to like the newly added screen recording frame very much
You can record the scene using the device as an mp4 format video file.
You can save
It is possible to record any device and the aspect ratio of the recorded video image is
The device screen analogy remains the same
This cool new feature can be run through the adb shell screen record command
The clutter is also available through the DMS panel in Clichy and Android Studios.
Can be used
Another Android 4.4
Storage-related features have also been added
The storage access framework has been added, and officially sms content
Providers are supported
Through the storage access framework, users can access data stored
You can easily access all of the document image files that exist on the cloud.
can
If you are creating an application that handles documents quickly
Through the crates document or the open document tent,
Storage companies can interlock with spraying users can use the system ui
You can increase the number of files provided by the promoter through
You can create a new file
The results are available through the activity Regents callback
If you want to add a new storage provider
I need to get a new reach Montfort provider
The following four methods can be overridden to represent a file.
You can browse, read and save any data you want
There is
And the most recent keynote permission in the manifest file,
I need to add a provider intent filter
When the app is installed, this new provider is automatically registered and the user
When you want to read or create a file using the storage access framework
System ui allows access to new providers
Expensive meetings of my development team
How to create a new provider
We've got a Daewoo video on how to take advantage of the Stories access framework.
I prepared
For more information, please see the video
Until now, we've opened a lot of sms-based
Now that you've created your app, you can edit it to take advantage of the new official API
It's time to
For the TKE, the content provider for sms will finally
The ability to set up your own default messaging app
Added
When you receive the message, the system will forward it to your default messaging app.
A new intent called sms debugger is used
Except for the default app, other apps, like previous ones,
You can check the received message and read the message through the sms provider
Can see
However, only the user-specified default new messages are sent to the ms provider
You can write directly on
It's possible to send a message even if it's not your default app.
The Android Android system replaces the message in the ms provider
You can add and write in other apps
You can check out the default messaging app for future messaging apps
For more information, please see Adam's Loan Byte video
And in Android 4.4
A new feature that helps applications interact with the real world
Added a lot
Bluetooth hid for peripherals such as mouse joystick keyboard
For over-watch tt profile and near-term message representation
Supports Bluetooth map profile
And an api to support the infrared receiver built into the device
Added
infrared receiver via APi Station and supporting frequency band still
I can see the information.
You can also transmit infrared signals directly.
Post card emulation, hc
Built-in fc card payment and membership card without the security elements
The process of transmitting and receiving nfc-based data such as traffic cards
Can be expressed to handle
In addition, to support the new feel mode,
The application can be implemented to read the transition information of the nfc card.
There is
Android h is smart card that complies with iso 7816 standard
Can emulate
At the time of data transaction, it is strict 4443 protocol 4 again
When determining which trench transition is forwarded to an app, the iso
7816 Actually sociable application follows the identity fire standard
And for Kiki,
Supports printer features. Wi-Fi virtue is like a Google Cland
Added api to control cloud-based printers
With this new pens apr you can express it as an Android canvas
You can easily output all kinds of content
Android is using pdf as the default file format for printing
The image is converted into a bitmap and output using the focus helper class
Content can be converted to pdf divided into pages and output
E-cube and WebView-based
ui is provided
Of course, if you know how to draw the content,
You can also draw content on the canvas and use it as a pdf
Naz is far away
How to use the panning feature in Android on Devvyte Video
I have compiled the contents
Kiki can improve the battery efficiency of applications that utilize sensors.
All the batches have been added
Batch mode allows you to play your app every time there is a
It collects the results for a certain period of time and delivers the application. Therefore,
An app process can remain in a low-power state until it receives placement results.
There is
You can adjust the interval at which you will receive the results, and if necessary
You can request data directly at any time
Two new sensors have been added
The step detection sensor can detect the moment when the user starts to walk,
The counting sensor can measure the number of steps you take like a network view
2 Sensor Module To minimize battery usage,
There is
So far, we have a quick look at the new api
There are a few big changes being made besides Android Kiki
First, the clone is based on a moth project, and a map bone matt has been newly implemented
Equipped with the same level of performance and compatibility as the Android Chrome browser
Supports html5 standard technologies and includes v8 JavaScript engine
There is
Also look out for other characters that are written from right to left
An API has been added for convenient support
Mirroring is a function of the Pseudo-Locale for only minutes to auto-mirroring
When you declare
Users who have selected 15k for sickness will automatically
I lend it to you on the screen.
You do not need to have a duplicate list to support the sick environment.
Using the Alkie idle roadkel feature, devices can be
Layout changes to
This allows you to lay out your layout without having to
You can test
Good news for those who are developing important apps
There is
For Android Kiki, you can also use the
Can be used
Using the new plus c plus plus api with ndk ndk
As with using the framework api, take advantage of the vendor scrap
can
It supports both skate installation and features such as custom tunnels
Finally, there are a number of security improvements
All of the internal s2 linux goes from false seed mode to infocode mode
Changed and improved encryption algorithm Added ellipses to keystore
It supports algorithmic digital signature algorithm
The entire disk is encrypted at the time of encryption to protect the q, especially the par
3 function applied
Also, as you all know, one important thing is that a new device
Released
It's the Nexus Five. Go to Google Play to see more details
You can buy it right away
Developers always need new development samples
Finally, Android 4.4 sdk is down through sdk manager
You can receive
Also, when you visit ComSite with two of the developer's answers, the new Android Ticket
You can read more about the version Thanks